grand theft auto has left a mark on the
pop culture landscape that few
franchises have done before or since to
mark the 20th anniversary of gta 3 and
the announcement of gta trilogy the
definitive edition let's take a look at
the history of grand theft auto
in the early 90s dma design a scottish
developer known best for the cutesy but
slightly sadistic lemmings series was
experimenting with a top-down game of
cops and robbers known then as race and
chase the four and a half year
development wasn't exactly easy only one
person on the team had ever actually
shipped a game before and the team
butted heads constantly over direction
and scale
as most games in development do it
evolved they realized it wasn't fun
playing as the police so that was
dropped a horror theme which would have
the players running over zombies even
emerged at one point the team's wish to
create a living breathing city caused
headaches and constantly needed to be
tweaked and scaled back
a bug led to the police cars becoming
really aggressive which turned out to be
incredibly fun so the game was tweaked
so that the police were really out to
get you rather than just try and pull
you over
the name was changed partly because
there were matchbox sets called race and
chase and partly to reflect the game's
new criminal direction
despite dma design feeling like they
were really onto something publisher bmg
interactive kept wanting to cancel the
game even up to three months out from
completion
sam and dan hauser brothers who worked
at bmg and championed the game early on
helped to get it out the door the game
titled grand theft auto was finally
released in 1997 on pc with a
playstation version following a few
months later
even back then the game contained a lot
of the core dna that gta would be known
for you play as a rookie criminal
looking to improve your reputation by
taking on various jobs in three
different fictional cities san andreas
vice city and liberty city
the jobs are straightforward ferry
passengers take out gang rivals be a
getaway driver you are free to choose
how and when to do them but you'd only
complete each level by reaching a set
target amount of chaos caused too much
bother though and your wanted level
increased and the cops were on your ass
you could respray your car to lose them
for a while but the more chaos you
created the tougher the response would
end up being
speaking of response the original gta
certainly had a big one in the uk its pr
was handled by the now disgraced
publicist max clifford who deliberately
courted controversy for attention by
stirring up a public outcry with
carefully placed newspaper articles that
all but guaranteed that politicians
would get involved this led to
discussions in the uk parliament about
banning the game before it even launched
some countries such as brazil did ban
gta for its violent content reviews of
the game were mixed most critics weren't
impressed by the graphics but admitted
that it was a huge amount of fun and
gave enormous praise for its sound work
in particular the radio stations that
would play whenever you got in and out
of vehicles
it sold a million copies in its first
year and dma knew they were onto
something
in 1998 gta's original publisher bmg
interactive was shut down by its parent
company and take two interactive swooped
in to buy up its assets including the
rights to grand theft auto and some key
personnel such as the hauser brothers
rockstar games was formed that year
more grand theft auto was on the way but
it wasn't a fully fledged sequel instead
gta london 1969 was an expansion pack
developed by rockstar canada in a
basement under a fruit shop the team
described making the game as more like a
rom hack than building anything from
scratch in fact the hardest part was
switching the driver's side and changing
the traffic logic so cars would drive on
the other side of the road
understandably as the team was made up
of mostly canadians they had to do a lot
of research on british culture to get
the lingo right the team watched a lot
of british movies like the italian job
and read things like viz magazine
by the way this is an extremely
different publication to the american
viz just fyi as a result london 1969 was
filled to the brim with british islands
and references like big bend sound
effects character names that were a nod
to beloved british celebrities and
crucial text was replaced with something
distinctly more british
listen right we're looking for a lad who
can do his stuff
i've heard you're a bit tasty no messing
around or you get a slap a second
expansion pack grand theft auto london
1961 was released a few months later it
was free and only available on pc it was
set eight years before the previous
expansion and featured the same
characters but new vehicles missions and
a new multiplayer map based on the
northern city of manchester
1999 was a packed year for gta with
developer dma design and publisher
rockstar releasing grand theft auto 2 in
october of that year
set in anywhere city usa gta 2 had a
sort of retro-futuristic vibe to it and
the game experimented and built on what
the developers had created with the
original gta for example you could now
spend points to save your game and
undertake jobs from different syndicates
doing so would build your rep with one
group allowing you to take on different
jobs with them but sour your
relationship with the others the game
doesn't feature any cutscenes to tell
its story and its intro was spliced
together from gta 2 the movie a short
film written by dan hauser it features
the bill and eastenders actor scott
maslin as a criminal on the run from the
police and an assassin in new york even
getting his car sprayed to evade
detection just like in the game looking
back on it though it's a very 1999 piece
of filmmaking
[Music]
gta 2 had pretty mixed reviews and
didn't like the world on fire as much as
the first game did in his review for
gamespot jeff gerstmann said that
occasionally it felt like a glorified
mission pack for the first game and
mentioned that its multiplayer was
pretty sluggish even over a lan
connection but he did praise its music
it was clear that the 2d era of gta was
on the out and with the shiny 3d
graphics dominating the video game
industry at the time thanks to the
playstation something had to change
[Music]
and change it did grand theft auto 3 was
the first game in the series to be 3d
and despite a lukewarm reception at that
year's e3 it was a huge success going on
to change open world games as we know
them for rockstar and dma it was a whole
new challenge not only were they working
to populate and bring a 3d world to life
but they had to balance non-linear and
story-driven gameplay so that players
felt like they had stuff to do but also
the freedom to do whatever they wanted
with so many plates to spin a decision
was made during development to keep the
protagonist silent in fact we didn't
actually even know his name until san
andreas came out after being betrayed by
his girlfriend claude manages to escape
imprisonment and gets tied up with the
mafia in liberty city as they knock
heads with the triads yakuza and cartel
its voice cast also included some huge
names like michael madsen i want you to
destroy their laundry vans and mangle
any triad [ __ ] that gets in your way
kyle mclachlan my property will be
waiting for you with the customs hanger
in the aircraft fuselage and soprano
stars frank vincent and joe pantaliano
remember no one messes with my girls
gameplay-wise it was a whole new world
the impact of making the game 3d cannot
be understated liberty city was unlike
anything anyone had ever really seen or
played in before it teamed with life as
well as opportunities for mischief
the game was actually delayed due to the
911 attacks in new york according to
author harold greenberg the houses
considered cancelling it altogether with
sam saying to his brother dan this
beautiful city has been attacked and now
we're making a violent crime drama set
in a city that's not unlike new york
city
my god i'm terrorized where i live and
on top of that we've got this [ __ ]
crazy game that is not exactly where
people's heads are at right now the game
ended up being delayed for three weeks
as rockstar removed references and
gameplay that would be inappropriate in
a post 911 world the biggest change was
the cover art but the colour scheme of
the police cars was changed to look less
like the nypd gta 3 was a behemoth and
rockstar was unstoppable it was lauded
by critics and sits at a 97 on
metacritic it was the highest selling
game in the states in 2001 despite
launching in late october and according
to 2008 take two financials it sold 14.5
million units in seven years but it
wasn't without its controversies along
with outrage at its violence there was a
huge outcry when it was discovered that
players could hire and then kill a
prostitute to get their money back the
game was banned and recalled in
australia only being re-released when
the sexual content was cut rockstar take
two sony and walmart was sued after two
teens shot two people claiming that they
were inspired by playing a gta
[Applause]
vice city started life as a mission pack
for gta 3 but after realizing that they
were coming up with too many ideas for a
simple expansion pack rockstar decided
to make a completely new game the team
settled on 80s miami partly because of
sam house's love of miami vice but also
because it was a setting they had
previously wanted to use in a mission
pack for the original gta samhauser said
that 80s miami was the quote grooviest
era of crime because it didn't really
feel like crime rockstar and the newly
bought dma design which was later
renamed rockstar north wanted to change
up the core concept of the game instead
of a revenge plotline they wanted to
focus on building a criminal empire you
could become a kingpin by buying assets
like taxi companies and strip clubs and
then rake in the rewards once you've
completed their associated missions
after a silent protagonist in gta 3 vice
city's tommy vasetti was anything but
being voiced by goodfellas star ray
liotta that they're more criminals in
this town than in prison in fact the
whole game was packed full of stars
including luis guzman what do you think
you're doing
gary busey hey
stupid with me and british icon danny
dyer
it's another drink
while the performances were well
received rockstar actually started
pairing back on using huge names as
protagonists with samhauser revealing
later that he was questioning whether he
was playing as tommy or playing as ray
liotta by city was a pit at the time it
was the fastest selling game in history
and the biggest game of 2002. it
received universal critical acclaim but
just like gta 3 before it it had its
fair share of controversies many
advocacy groups lobbied for it to be
banned politicians threatened to sue
take two interactive and jack thompson
remember him kept filing suits against
sony and take two claiming a number of
murders committed by young men were
inspired by gta
[Applause]
[Music]
passenger show us your hands
get down on your knees
the records set by vice city were
smashed by san andreas which became the
highest selling playstation 2 game of
all time
san andreas takes place in 1992 in a
fictionalized version of california
former gang member cj returns home after
his mother's death and is framed for the
murder of a cop he reconnects with old
friends and falls back into the gangster
lifestyle oh [ __ ] here we go again
san andreas toyed with more rpg elements
making cj really customizable you could
change his outfit hairstyle tattoos and
more cj needed to eat well and exercise
to stay healthy doing so would impact
physical attributes and how other
characters would respond to him certain
skills would increase through repeated
use such as driving shooting and running
you could also swim and climb it was a
whole new world to earn cash there were
a multitude of mini-games including
gambling and you could take over enemy
gang turf using gang members as backup
cj could have girlfriends and that
landed rockstar in some hot water or
should i say hot coffee during
development a sex minigame was in san
andreas but was removed before the game
released someone on the internet
discovered it by combing through the
game files and released a mod that
allowed players to enable it this caused
something of a storm leading the esrb to
reclassify san andreas as an adult-only
game therefore restricting where it
could be sold it became a hot button
political topic too the ftc launched an
investigation and hillary clinton got
involved leading to her face being
included in gta 4 on the statue of
liberty the game was patched by rockstar
and the new version without the sex
minigame was able to be sold at its
original rating
rockstar released the handheld grand
theft auto advance on the same day as
san andreas advance acted as a prequel
to gta 3 but reverted to the top-down 2d
stylings of the original games while you
meet characters like 8-ball from gta 3
throughout the course of the story the
protagonist mike was pretty forgetful
and the game was ultimately overshadowed
by the success of san andreas
[Music]
one prequel to gta 3 clearly wasn't
enough and rockstar released another in
2005 this time for the psp
liberty city stories follows gta 3's
tony cipriani after his return from
exile due to killing a member of the
mafia the game featured a wireless
multiplayer mode as well as some
gameplay mechanics from san andreas like
gang wars and character outfits liberty
city stories ended up being the highest
selling psp game of all time followed by
vice city stories
this one acted as a prequel to vice city
where you play as vic vance rick vance
reporting for duty sir a minor character
who dies in the opening of vice city the
biggest gameplay change was the addition
of empire building borrowing ideas from
vice city and san andreas you could
purchase or take over enemy sites and
build businesses on them to generate
revenue rival gangs will attack and you
need to protect and maintain your
businesses fail to do so and they get
put up for sale
[Applause]
[Music]
2006 microsoft press conference then
xbox boss peter moore rolled up his
sleeve to reveal a fake tattoo that
served to announce gta 4 and the promise
that it would launch on the 360 on the
same day as pc and playstation 3.
alongside that he revealed that
exclusive episodic content would be
available on xbox live for this next
generation gta rockstar went all out
bringing together teams from new york
edinburgh lincoln and san diego to work
on the project the team wanted the world
to be the most important element of the
game with writer dan hauser calling
liberty city gta 4's biggest character
it wasn't the biggest map that rockstar
had made but it was the densest the team
wanted liberty city to feel like a
living breathing world with more of a
focus on realism than they'd done before
extensive research was undertaken in new
york with rockstar opting not to
recreate the city faithfully but to
capture its key characteristics the art
style was less cartoony and using
state-of-the-art performance capture
tech made the characters feel more
lifelike protagonist nico was able to
keep up with friends via his mobile
phone and there were countless fake
in-game brands tv shows and radio
stations that grounded you in a more
realistic world
nico it's roman let's go bowling early
trailers for the game made it look like
gta had lost that edgy cartoon humor and
was going in a new more serious
direction
which it did and didn't it was a little
more serious yes but gta 4 was still
full of wacky irreverent characters and
was the sandbox playground we all
expected unlike other gta games that
really wore their cinematic influences
proudly gta 4 was consciously trying not
to be so referential instead trying to
focus on telling a new story about
eastern european war veteran nico bellic
moving to liberty city to live the
american dream upon arriving it's clear
that the tales told to him by his cousin
roman were a little tall where's barbara
with big titties and stephanie who sucks
like a vacuum what are you talking about
and nico gets involved in the criminal
life that he was hoping to leave behind
after feeling that san andreas was a
little linear dan hauser pushed to
implement player choice into some of the
gta 4 missions which involved sparing or
killing certain characters multiplayer
was designed as an extension of single
player and you could access it via
niko's mobile phone gta 4 was also the
first game to utilize the rockstar games
social club an online social network
that allows players to compare
statistics fight for leaderboard spaces
as well as upload their own pictures and
videos this might surprise you but gta 4
was an enormous success critically it
got tens across the board and holds a 98
on metacritic making it the third
highest rated game of all time it was
also the fastest selling entertainment
product at the time making 500 million
dollars in its first week this record
would then be broken by its sequel but
before we get there it's time to talk
about some more spin-offs and expansions
the last and damned was the first
expansion for gta 4 and was one of the
two hinted at by peter mort back in
2006. rockstar said that it had built
this huge world for gta 4 but it was
limiting to only set one story in it so
lost and damned took place at the same
time as gta 4 and its other expansion
the ballad of gay tony it featured a lot
of familiar faces like nico but the game
was played from the perspective of
johnny acting president of the lost
motorcycle club as a result the game was
more focused on brotherhood rather than
climbing the criminal ladder from the
very bottom johnny would later make an
appearance in gta 5 but it didn't
exactly end well for him
chinatown was released for the nintendo
ds and the psp in 2009 and it followed
huang li a member of the triads as he
fights to recover his dead father's
stolen sword as it was released on the
ds rockstar used a lot of interaction
via the touch screen the game wasn't
quite top down utilizing more of a
floating isometric camera and its
graphics looked more cartoony and cell
shaded while the buying and selling of
drugs in the game was deemed
controversial it's a gta game of course
there had to be some controversy
somewhere it was very highly praised
upon release critics were amazed with
how rockstar managed to squeeze liberty
city onto the ds and gamespot's review
said that this isn't just a ds version
of gta this is a fantastic game that
advances the series
[Music]
back to those downloadable expansions
for gta 4 and the ballad of gay tony
capped off a busy year for gta releases
you play as luis lopez in deep debt and
weighing up whether or not to sell out
his partner tony before tony sells him
out gay tony and the lost and damned
were later released as a standalone
double pack that you could play without
needing the base game
[Music]
[Music]
which brings us to gta 5. development
began at rockstar north shortly after
the release of gta 4 and over time the
gta 5 team worldwide grew to over a
thousand developers drawing on the three
protagonists from gta 4 and its
expansions and with a wish to innovate
and push themselves rockstar opted for
not one but three protagonists that you
can switch between you couldn't switch
if you were on a mission but if you were
in free roam trevor michael or franklin
would just a button press away the
camera would automatically zoom out and
pan to your chosen character in the
middle of doing whatever it is they're
doing to give a sense that the world
carried on while you weren't around the
three played off each other wonderfully
the three
and the different lives they led all
felt fleshed out and had their own
stories and characters that you wanted
to follow the three have an
interconnected story and frequently
group up with the eventual goal of
stealing a whole lot of money heists
were inspired by the reception to the
gta 4 mission three leaf clover and were
the key points in the game tricky jobs
that the characters had to meticulously
plan to efficiently pull off if doing
the main story wasn't for you there were
a multitude of minigames to choose from
or you could use the game as a playbox
to make some yourself as with gta 4 the
team did a huge amount of research to
create los santos and the surrounding
area in 5. the map was huge and stuffed
with things to do with the ability to
swap characters easily as well as a
multitude of lands and air vehicles
getting around was not only easy but
intoxicating los santos was full of
wacky characters side missions as well
as secrets like a certain mount chiliad
mystery it was also the first game in
the series to actually have its own
score on top of the radio stations that
featured licensed music it was the
biggest gta to date and in terms of
gameplay an evolution and triumph for
the series it was the most hotly
anticipated game of the year and upon
release received glowing scores it
brought in one billion dollars in just
three days making it the biggest
entertainment launch of all time it's
also the second best-selling game of all
time just after minecraft and it smashed
all records held by gta4 it was
re-released a year later for xbox one
and playstation 4 consoles with improved
weather effects and increased draw
distance as well as a new first person
mode a pc version followed in 2015 and
it's set to be released again on ps5 and
xbox series x and s in 2022
while the world waits for another
mainline gta game rockstar has been
updating its wildly popular grand theft
auto online the multiplayer that was
released a couple of weeks after gta 5.
after a slightly rocky launch which was
patched pretty quickly it's become the
main vehicle for gta updates with meaty
free content packs every year or so
online is conceived as a continually
evolving separate experience and allows
you to create a character and build your
own empire either alone or with a crew
of friends every big update adds new
modes cosmetics missions and even
characters from previous games like tony
from ballad of gay tony heists the
beloved centerpiece of gta 5 were a huge
addition that came to online in 2015.
online has really taken on a world of
its own people make their own game modes
and even role play on its servers while
everyone is championing it the bit for
gta 6 gta online is still wildly popular
it frequently appears in the top played
games on twitch and steam it's due to be
released as a standalone experience in
2022 on ps5 and on xbox series x and s
the british genius behind the most
lucrative video game ever this is beyond
what film can do hot off the heels of
the historic launch of gta 4 you
couldn't escape rockstar games and the
bbc decided to make a docudrama about
sam hauser and jack thompson's legal
battle following the release of vice
city as well as the hot coffee fallout
it had a pretty star-studded cast
including harry potter himself daniel
radcliffe as sam hauser and aliens star
bill paxton as jack thompson in surely a
bad sign for everyone at the bieb take
two interactive filed suit against the
bbc for trademark infringement before
the game changes even aired saying that
they tried to resolve the matter with
the bbc multiple times with no success
the movie didn't exactly go down well
with fans either it was full of weird
continuity errors like images from gta 4
and 5 being visible in the background of
shots despite the movie being set
between 2002 and 2006. there's also a
scene where they're watching a hot
coffee video on youtube despite youtube
not existing yet
and there was some very questionable
understanding of how games actually made
after its launch rockstar tweeted this
absolute all-timer was basil brush busy
what exactly is this random made up
bollocks funnily enough it's pretty
impossible to track the film down these
days
in october 2021 rockstar announced that
to celebrate the 20th anniversary of gta
3 it would bring 3 san andreas and vice
city to current generation platforms
including nintendo switch and later
mobile offering graphical and modern
gameplay enhancements
so there you have it the history of one
of the most venerated video game series
of all time for more on gta keep your
eyes peeled to gamespot because this
powerhouse ain't slowing down anytime
soon and we'll have all the latest for
more deep dives into your favorite games
make sure to like this video and
subscribe to gamespot i'm on twitter at
lucy james games and i'll catch you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you